flight and sarah knights is our crew
member seven so for those of you that
tuned in for our first flight they have
uh basically swapped roles uh for the
day both of them extraordinarily well
trained in both of those roles and
they're both outstanding people to be
guiding our astronauts to space and back
all right we're gonna uh i look forward
to seeing more from kevin actually
because he's got some some great words
to share with our uh with our astronauts
once they're on board the capsule and of
course uh through their flight yes and
let's step through some milestone
moments that are going to unfold right
after the coin ceremony
first at around t minus 44. we'll get
that go for astronaut load uh at this
point our astronauts will board those
riviens that ariane mentioned earlier
they definitely look like spaceships
especially with the juxtaposition of the
desert here
once they're in the riviens our
astronauts will drive down the road to
space out to the launch pad it's about
two miles and once they get down there
of course it's photo time because if you
didn't take a photo it's not on the gram
never happened it's not on the grammy
so they'll get their crew photo at this
point and once they disembark from the
riviens they'll begin to ascend that
tower i know captain kirk and crew
probably wish they could be transported
into the capsule but we don't have that
technology quite our advanced
development program is working on a
jacket we have jackie we just have to be
patient i have confidence
once they ascend the tower they'll
briefly be in their safety room at the
top and they're awaiting word to ingress
the crew capsule they'll get all buckled
up with crew member seven and we
anticipate about t minus 29 minutes for
that hatch to close now a t-minus 24
minutes
again we close the hatch and that's when
kevin sprogue in capcom takes over and
we move into the final countdown which
of course takes us to the best part the
launch
and that mission ends once the crew
capsule safely touches down back here in
the west texas desert and then it's
celebration time it's champagne showers
champagne showers rocket launches
champagne showers right and we'll have
welcomed back four brand new astronauts
to earth now today's crew will have a
special guest traveling with them during
the astronaut loading process our
founder jeff bezos will be with the uh
astronauts all the way up the tower and
to the crew capsule some incredible
moments to look for today i
kind of fun to have jeff bezos himself
you know beat her your chauffeur out to
the rocket that's not that's not too
shabby oh no that's a pretty special
crew member eight and we're gonna have
to make sure he actually disembarks at
the end and doesn't want to try and go
up with them again i know i know he had
we know he had a really good time on the
first time around a good thing we got
those cameras up there
okay jackie why don't we take a quick
breather here and let's everybody let's
check out new shepherd on the pad as she
gets ready to fly to space and back
today with our second human space flight
crew
[Laughter]
welcome back everybody if you're just
joining us we're about t minus one hour
and three minutes to go until our second
human crew launches to space and back
in just a few minutes we are going to
bring you the special coin ceremony that
we noted earlier but before we do that
why don't we talk about the road to
space today is all about new shepard but
down in florida we're hard at work
building our orbital rocket new glen
this is the rocket that will pave the
road to space
[Music]
we took the first huge step with first
human flight on new shepard and new
glenn is going to be the next huge step
for the origin
you have to put the infrastructure in
place to give us a road to space where
we could actually maintain a permanent
presence in space and new glenn is the
key to all of that
the scale from new shepard to new glenn
is humongous new shepard is the single
stage that gets you into suborbital this
takes you to orbital space
we are building a rocket and a launch
site that can put more payload into
space than anybody else we're going to
be launching blue origin developed
payloads lunar landers and human space
flight the scale of what's coming with
new glenn is just
unbelievable this is a huge vehicle this
thing's massive and it's it's modern
it's reusable it's new hardware that's
going to be changing the game and it's
going to be the next generation of
launch vehicle
we're in the space coast of florida
where all the action is where the
history of human space flight started
it's been amazing to watch this launch
site grow up
first started here was a couple
equipment pieces here and there but now
it's flourishing it's super exciting
it's a huge job to bring a rocket like
the new blend together it only happens
with diligent teamwork it's a lot of
dedication from a lot of teams across
blue
we have engineers we have electricians
we have technicians it takes a lot of
teamwork dedication just passion for
this mission it's not about us having a
day in and day out job
it's about having a vision that's way
bigger than all of us building a road to
space to me means paving the way for
having that infrastructure to make space
more accessible to provide
access to space for everyone builder
roles to space means we're working on a
legacy that will last 100 years and
longer
i'm jerry gleckel i'm emory coles justin
white sandy lee dave powell allison
carone kelsey krommer meg dalton hoffman
i'm jennifer oldham and i'm building a
road to space i'm building the road to
space i'm building a road to space i'm
building a road to space i'm building a
road to space
[Music]
i mean wow the progress down at our cape
facility is truly amazing i'm always
shocked at the incremental just huge
leaps forward i remember the first time
i went down to the cape the factory had
just opened and it was essentially just
a large empty building
and at this point we have over 1 million
square feet of manufacturing space a
brand new launch complex built from the
ground up i mean it's truly mind-blowing
with hardware being built and also i
mean it's not just a building or two it
is a campus down there by now it's
really cool that's right and as you
could tell in the video the road to
space is powered by people if you'd like
to be one of the people building that
road we're growing and hiring across all
of our groups here at blue origin come
work with some of the smartest people
solving some of the toughest and most
interesting challenges please visit our
website for more details and ariane it
was great to see some of that progress
on new glenn of course we're taking
lessons learned from new shepard
applying them to new glenn and new glenn
is powered actually by seven of our be4
engines that blue engine four and here's
blue origins be4 propulsion test
engineering manager sophia porter to
talk all about propulsion
this is launch site one and specifically
the test stand behind me is zeke's the
extreme engine experiment which is the
home of the be4 rocket engine
be4 is a reusable orbital class rocket
engine so we've really focused all of
the design and development of the e4
around reusability down to the smallest
details and here at zeek's we learn
every day in development about the
engine we test it out to make sure that
this engine is capable of delivering
payloads to the precise orbits that our
customers require
we have two test cells that are equally
capable here at zeeks and once those
engines are installed we perform all of
our checkouts we install our
ground-based sensors we run a series of
tests and then we ship the engines off
to their next destination
the individuals who are the life and
breadth of our site are engineers our
technicians our safety and quality and
administrative staff they come out here
to make rocket test operations and
launch operations a reality oftentimes
we have engineers who come here right
out of college and within a year they
are running engine tests themselves at
22 or 23 years old you could be making
the go no-go call for this engine
when you watch that engine fire when you
feel it through two sets of hearing
protection you feel it resonate in your
body it's just absolutely pure raw
energy
to watch that happen in real time is
incredibly inspiring and i can only
imagine when we watch the rocket
actually fly is going to be absolutely
an indescribable feeling
engine tests are always happening here
at blue you've been down here for these
tests before i have and you can hear it
you can feel it it's
truly unbelievable and because we're
here in this valley it just shakes the
entire valley as sophia said in the
video you just feel it rumbling in your
in your body and i just love that video
because it gives an opportunity to shine
a light on somebody like sophia porter
who herself you know she started out in
college as an intern here and just a
couple of years out of college she is
managing that test facility i mean that
is a big deal and that's the type of
stuff that you get to do here at blue
origin
here's
one of her beautiful uh her beautiful
tests that we had going on down in texas
that just happened just a couple of days
ago it's a beautiful pick
absolutely and we've been testing be4
and be3 and be3u out in west texas for
years at this point and so there's a lot
of amazing test time out here at our
private engine test facility and our
testing capabilities are actually going
to be expanding in a big way down at
huntsville in nasa marshall space flight
center we're actually we've taken over
historic test stand 4670 it's tested
saturn five for apollo space shuttle
main engines in the early rd-180s it's
been unutilized government property for
almost two decades and so that stan's
going to come back to life and do a lot
of our hot fires as well in addition to
our west texas capability and i don't
know how we're going to form the list
but i have to be there for that that
first test oh for the process or let me
say for all of them because i mean
you're basically going to live in or in
the control center if you do that no i
mean as jack you mentioned that so we're
going to continue to do engine testing
out here in west texas is where we do a
lot of our development testing on our
engines we've got two major test centers
uh you saw zeke's there we also have
geeks as we call it uh which is the
other test stand that focuses more on
our blue engine three the the engine
that is going to be uh propelling new
shepard into space but also the be3u
which is the upper stage variant they're
going to be two of those be 3us on the
upper stage of new glenn so they're
going to continue to do the development
testing out here in west texas and once
the beauty of being able to use 4670
is basically we produce the rocket
engines at our huntsville facility and
basically drive it down the road a
couple of miles where we can do
acceptance testing as you mentioned
before we
ship them down to the cape so a really
exciting activity from our engines group
that have been working absolutely and
you know one of the other beauties of
huntsville is we're close to our
customer united launch alliance two be4
engines will be on their vulcan and so
when we're hot firing out in huntsville
we'll be able to ship them right up to
decatur which is just a short drive
just uh just a short drive there yeah so
some when we talk about designing
rockets and and making them
operationally reusable it's it's one
thing to think about the operations but
there's also that that same mentality
and theme that is driven into the
manufacturing element of it as well
so i mean it's uh uh you know exciting
things that we've got going on all right
we are at t minus 54 seconds to go
t minus 54 minutes and 30 seconds excuse
me got a little bit more time than that
to go until launch my understanding is
that uh member seven sarah knights is
ready for the special coin ceremony to
seal their training and get them
underway why don't we watch that now
who's going to tell us when we're
oh we're on okay fantastic all right
astronauts i have one last special thing
for you
um this is a challenge coin that i have
right here
challenge coins have a long history but
classically they're awarded to show that
you belong
and that you've achieved something of
particular interest right
this is only awarded by crew member
seven
to astronauts who have passed training
and are just about to fly on new shepard
all of you have passed with
beautiful colors over the last couple of
days
and it's my very great honor to present
this to you for your flight today
each of you are just
helping us take that step
on the road space
and to enable a future where we have
millions of people living and working in
space to benefit earth and you are one
of these very few few very first
explorers and adventurers taking that
path with us so i'm giving this to you
today so you can put it in your flight
suit pocket take it with you on your
historic journey as you go up
and with this
you are go for lunch on new shepherds
all right
congratulations chris thank you
congratulations glenn thank you
congratulations audrey
can you read that one congratulations
bill
[Laughter]
that's beautiful you'll be known in
history for taking a pioneering first
step
well that was really special touch and
incidentally once that crew flies past
the carmen line that internationally
recognized line of space they'll be
recognized by the world as astronauts
and will soon be receiving another
special recognition item their astronaut
wings so also flying to space with each
one of those astronauts in addition to
the coin they're going to put in their
flight suit is a postcard from blue
origins club for the future each
astronaut made their own postcard during
training yeah and you can see them here
those that art is pretty impressive i
definitely couldn't do that that kind of
a job my artistry peaked at about age
seven so the figures are about
my ability um there's also thousands of
additional postcards flying in the
capsule with our crew today to date
we've flown and returned over 137
000 postcards to all of you out there
who've participated keep sending them
we'll keep flying them so while we're
talking about club we wanted to give you
an update on a few of the 99 non-profits
who received a 1 million grants from
club for the future in aggregate these
organizations are collectively impacting
tens of millions of students each year
and it's not just sparking their
imaginations but it's materially
impacting their education and ultimately
their passions and this is done through
immersive curriculum access to
access to experts and opportunities to
fly payloads like on new shepard and
much more why don't we take a look at
the latest from several club for the
future partners
[Music]
i'm here at space center houston it's a
nonprofit organization we rely on
charitable support to fulfill our goals
and aspirations
the grant from club for the future is
going to enable us to involve tens of
thousands of youth
to have this grant from club for the
future will allow us to accelerate our
efforts outside of aerospace to create a
broad membership of women in stem so
that the young women that we work with
can see the wide variety of possible
careers
we at aia have the goal of impacting one
million students a year rayon is an
example of exactly the kind of people we
need for this industry
my name is rayon harris i am 25 years
old and i am currently an aeronautical
design engineer my dreams my passion was
always airplanes joining an organization
known as american institute of
aeronautics and astronautics and double
a the diversity scholar program really
accelerated my path to really pursue my
passion after i graduated from awas i
was definitely going to give back so i
was a match with caleb a few months ago
with the mentor match program and so
it's really awesome to be able to use
experience which you've learned yourself
to really give back to them and also
make their experience as easy as
possible also get them as excited as
possible because it is very exciting
caleb is a 13 year old engineering
student at georgia tech helping us build
our future
my name is caleb anderson and
i am a third year at georgia technical
college and i'm currently studying to be
an aerospace engineer
i've really been interested in it space
in general just like all my life this is
really cool
that's what i think a club of the future
for doing something like this i think
having so much money be able to be
donated to an organization like this is
absolutely amazing it can really turn
the future the aerospace in the right
direction
i love hearing those inspirational
stories from club and their partner
organizations i mean rayon and caleb in
that video
pretty impressive keep up the amazing
work you guys
yeah we've we're inadequate yeah
let's be honest you guys are kicking
butt keep keep it up we can't wait to
pass the torch onto you to continue on
this road to space yes and it's exciting
to see club for the future growing and
making a difference it's also exciting
to see these partner organizations
making such great progress club is very
much a collaborative effort and let's
highlight another key partner doing some
incredible work with middle school
students project janos
[Music]
our mission at project janos is to
engage and educate students with the
wonders of space and to inspire them to
become explorers of it we do this
through a two-pronged approach the first
is a set of videos in which i as the
host ask questions of subject matter
experts working on the front lines of
space flight thanks to our partnership
with club for the future students get to
meet space architects engineers
scientists and others at blue origin
the second is the curriculum of
standards aligned activities designed to
inspire students to become explorers of
space themselves
we are teachers making lessons for
teachers we know what will keep the
students engaged and because this is a
project with nasa every aspect of it is
going to be a mission based set of
activities
students perform data literacy skills
engineering design loop processes and
prototype testing and building of
concepts
after watching a video on rocket
propulsion students get to build an
engine testing chamber and mix baking
soda and vinegar to study rocket
propellant ratios and thanks to club for
the future project yano's students can
design postcards that are actually flown
into space
students today will have the opportunity
to live and work in space when humans
return to the moon in a few years it'll
be to stay
we believe the best preparation for that
new reality is project yanos a unique
program that instills students with the
skill set and mindset needed to be
explorers of
space very impressive stuff over at
project giano's my friend josh bernstein
you know he's had a couple of um
successful tv shows on the history
channel on the discovery channel and
it's really lovely to see how somebody
like him wants to give back wants to get
back you know his ability to touch a lot
of people and he's doing that to harness
you know the the the potential of the
next generation so kudos to him and to
all the kids uh coming up
coming up along this road to space uh
future's looking pretty bright i mean
what a time that students at all ages in
their schools can have a space program i
mean it really i know we said it before
it's an incredible era i'm blown away by
all the brilliant kids out there the
future where millions of people live and
work in space isn't a tomorrow thing or
a next year thing it's going to be that
next generation now i should say you
know
we mentioned club for the future
has all sorts of partners that are doing
extraordinary work the club itself does
some wonderful work and actually
down here in van horn our home away from
home home away from home it's van horn
our our local team does a lot of work
with the with the local community i want
to highlight one of the projects uh that
we did in some of the local high school
students we collaborated and they are uh
going to they have designed and built in
fact the very first post box to space
let's check it out
the post box to space is the world's
very first mailbox that will take
letters from the earth
send them to space and then return them
to the senders
what a great drawing
this has been really an unprecedented
collaboration between club for the
future van horn high school and blue
origin it is an immense project that's
been taken on by seven juniors and
seniors of van horn high school who've
decided that they have an interest in
welding
they have worked very hard from design
all the way up through manufacturing
well we first started off with the
cardboard template after a few weeks of
planning and designing we eventually got
into the shop started welding together
the base
we took the rocket kind of design put
some legs on it and we're going to make
them look like fins
we've had a huge number of blue
employees who've cycled through here to
help us out in really substantial ways
it would not have been possible without
the support of a large number of blue
origin folks it is really great what
club for the future is doing that
they're even giving us this opportunity
to do things like this coming every week
and providing supplies paint metal
i learned how to use a torch to learn
how to weld better i learned a little
bit more about the process in designing
and mocking up a prototype
i truly hope that the students fully
recognize how substantial their post box
is going to be as a landmark in van horn
i'd like to invite the students to be
the very first to use our post box
and hopefully will be an inspiration to
all of the students who come through the
school
[Music]
so great to see again the the hard work
that our team down here in west texas
does not only on testing rocket engines
and and launching rockets but also
giving back to the community i said that
the relationship that we have is is
wonderful it really
it is home away from home it feels
really nice the people who are always
very welcoming you know they see us
walking around in our bloors and gear
give us high fives it's a it's a
wonderful place to be it is i drove past
the post box to space the other day and
just loved seeing that new landmark yeah
in downtown van horn it was really
awesome
all right we are at t minus 45 minutes
to go until launch we are on a brief
hold here we've said it before on
on webcast prior we want to make sure
that our teams are all aligned
i do understand that our astronauts have
made it into the riviens there they are
and look who their chauffeur is none
other than jeff bezos also in his flight
suit
jackie this makes me a little bit
concerned uh you had a hypothesis that
jeff might just stay on the rocket uh
that's not the plan for today just to be
very clear he's ready though
if that opportunity arises
and he's uh you know again from having
flown just a couple of months ago on our
first human flight of course with his
brother mark with wally funk national
treasure wally funk as well as our first
uh astronaut customer oliver damon uh
you know he's uh he's he's got some
important knowledge to impart upon our
next uh next crew here look they're
they're having a good conversation in
there absolutely and you know we'll have
to ask the crew
how many stars they would give jeff for
his his driving performance what is his
rating you know we'll have to check in
on that after well look i mean if it
starts with the with the wheels there i
mean the ribbon is it's a
it's a nice ride it's talk about rocket
ships
have you been in one yet did you get a
chance i haven't i've driven past them
but i have not had the opportunity to be
inside it is no blue cocktails for me no
being inside the ribbon we're going to
work on these things jackie we're going
to work on these things but no i mean it
really is the first time i've gotten one
uh the
the gentleman who was driving was like
you might want to put your head back
against the seat and i was like what are
you talking about it's fine he goes no
i'm serious and he accelerates and i'm
like oh we are out of here it is so much
fun those cars so yeah some pretty sweet
rides
sorry jackie again we're working on
we're working on it all right we
continue to to be in a hold here we've
said it before you know we spent years
uh designing and building these rockets
months designing these missions and
if we need a couple of
minutes there that is to to get the
teams aligned then uh then we're going
to take them so with that why don't we
take a look at new shepherd out on the
pad as she awaits her astronauts uh in
their in the arabian chariots to bring
them out to the pad
foreign
all right thank you everybody for
joining us live from west texas at our
launch site one we're at t minus 45
minutes and of one second to go until
launch we are in a brief hold here of
course we want to make sure that our
teams are all aligned that the uh that
the winds are in bounds of course that
has been the story of the last couple of
days or those gusty winds um but again
want to make sure that everything is all
sorted for our launch but while we have
a minute here i wanna you know we just
saw the crew in the rivien vehicles um
and they've been down here the last
couple of days but you know
the launch to space the training is part
of the experience but so is kind of the
hospitality component component at our
astronaut village so i want to show you
a little bit more
about our uh our astronaut village here
we've got um
so the astronaut village itself is just
about 10 minutes away from the launch
site itself you can see nestled in the
the beautiful valley of west texas
it's built around that that fire pit but
each uh astronaut gets um this pretty
luxe uh um airstream it's kitted out on
the inside very very nicely and our our
hospitality team they've got decades of
experience uh and they really make you
make you feel like you are
you know like you are part of an
adventure um i can say i had the the
good opportunity of being able to
experience this just a couple of months
ago as i got to go through my training
and it it it really it really rounds it
out you know and when we built
uh the the astronaut village and the
hospitality component of this we wanted
we wanted to build something that that
really felt part of this texas
environment it's not something big and
elaborate it's something that is part of
the environment but of course at the
same time we want you to feel
comfortable so we brought in a wonderful
uh catering staff um you know there's
nothing like going to space so you're
talking about champagne showers after
the uh
after the launch you know but the but
the the food and beverage uh is uh is
very nice there's nothing nothing like a
glass of champagne around the uh around
the campfire absolutely and as you can
see you know everything is very designed
so that the crew can get to know each
other
and relax and have that comfort as they
prepare for their flight to space um oh
there's ariane right there with audrey
powers was also also going out to fly
the bonding i think that's a really
important point that you bring up jackie
is the bonding component you know i had
the i was chatting with uh with chris uh
boss housing who actually is a good
friend of mine and he uh you know he was
saying one of the things that he's
really loved so far about this
experience is he really feels
so close now and they haven't gone to
space yet but so close to you know to to
audrey and to glenn and to and to bill
through this experience and and again we
have thought about it in a in a holistic
uh in a holistic kind of way so
to all of you that are out there
watching if you want to experience this
the the flight to space the the the
hospitality the the the bonding it is
really cool we really we encourage you
to go to bloorian.com click on the link
there fly to space and uh and let us
know and we'll reach out uh to you after
the after the flight
okay we're at t-minus 45 minutes to go
we continue to be in a hold here while
we've got some more time why don't we
throw it back to the rocket
um
funny
uh
thank you again everybody for joining us
live from west texas at our launch site
one for our second human flight ns18
we're at t-minus 45 minutes to go until
launch we continue to be in a brief hold
here well have you got some time let's
continue to watch our beautiful new
shepard rocket as she awaits her
astronauts
thank you again everybody for joining us
live for ns18 our second human flight
here at blue origin
our team is working uh on the vehicle
readiness we've got a couple of items
that were taken off here this is normal
in rocket launch land so why don't we
continue to check out new shepard as she
readies for her flight to space and back
today
fighting
sounds good
all right everybody welcome back we are
t minus 45 minutes to go until launch we
are continuing to be in a hold here as
we uh make sure that our rocket is ready
to go to space otherwise everything else
looking good
we are going to continue to watch new
shepard on the pad as she ready to go to
space and back today
so
oh
you
all right thank you everybody for
joining us live for ns18 blue origin
second human flight we are t minus 44
minutes and 27 seconds to go thank you
so much for your patience as our team
worked to make sure that our vehicle is
ready for flight and it looks like
everything is all set and sorted and my
understanding is you know what we are go
for astronaut load how exciting is that
let's check out the uh let's check out
the astronauts back in their riviens
here
there they are ready to go to space
you see in the uh back left that is
audrey powers
in the front right there's chris
smiles and waves smiles
and there they go chris boss housing
glenn devries audrey powers and captain
kirk himself william shatner have just
started their journey to the launch pad
into the crew capsule and off to space
you can just i i have goosebumps i can
feel their anticipation looking at the
oh
this is awesome words of encouragement
from team blue along the way absolutely
there to get the the cheers and the the
hoots and the hollers from team blue
once they pass uh they're gonna drive
about another couple hundred yards
out to uh towards in front of the
mission control
facility there
get a couple more words of words of
encouragement that there in fact is
their friends and family that have uh
that have flown down here to texas
to watch them go to space and back
and here they come they're approaching
our mission control center
and just on the right there you can see
what we call the barn that is the
facility where we keep our rockets of
course we've got the rocket out there on
the pad as well as the second rocket
that flew just a couple of weeks ago
that one is dedicated to payload flights
it's really amazing to see all the
demand we've seen for those payload
flights to the point where we're able to
have a full separate booster
specifically dedicated to doing this
important research in science and you
know jackie one day and we are going to
combine those payloads and the
astronauts to do some tended payload
flights uh just a a wonderful
opportunity for many scientists and
engineers around the world who want to
develop their technology maybe they
don't need to go to orbital space they
just need a couple minutes of beautiful
clean micro gs and that's what they get
with these uh with these flights on new
shepard now you see the two vehicles
have taken a left and they are on their
road to space
jackie i can tell you from having done
the uh the the uh the astronaut training
just a couple of months ago
so i got to do everything minus
get inside of uh of a rocket that was up
uh on the launch tower but we did all of
this because we had to coordinate it of
course um and
that the drive out there there's
there's this this interesting mix of
adrenaline because you're you're
basically harnessing and and containing
your own adrenaline you're trying to
kind of level it out but it's also very
peaceful right it is this two-mile uh
road that goes out to the launch pad out
to the rocket and you're there with your
thoughts you know i i
these these four astronauts have been
thinking about going to space for a long
long time and this moment
is here
i have to know what was on the playlist
when you drove down the road to space i
know that mine would have an excessive
amount of pit bull i don't know if
that's a little too hyped for this
experience
but hopefully they're listening to some
rocket man or something yeah exactly
rocketman was definitely on the uh on
the playlist as we as we head out there
now jackie once they uh they head out
the road to space there is the ring road
uh that goes around the launch pad they
are going to go to the north end of the
ring road and they're going to stop and
take a photo take a couple of beautiful
photos right before their uh
they get back in the the rivians head
back to the base of the launch tower
where they will ascend the the tower and
stop in the safety shelter first yeah
and you can see a good view of that
safety shelter right now that's that
white box on top of the launch tower
you can tell those that the pensive look
they're all taking in taking in the
moment as they should i can only can
only imagine being in that i see all
smiles from astronaut powers so that's
very exciting
have a good view of that ring road now
which is that circular ring surrounding
the launch pad as ariane mentioned
they go they're checking it out
now from
the training to
cruising in your rivians to the launch
to the landing this really is a once in
a lifetime opportunity
if you guys are watching out there and
you want to be one of those astronauts
on on the way to space really encourage
you visit gloria.com and click on fly to
space we'd love to see you on that
rocket and uh let's be honest frankly
we'd love to be on that rocket with you
if you could put in your note that you
specifically want to fly with jackie and
ariane maybe
we'll see what can be done there
the astronauts are getting out of their
rivien getting those smiles ready for
that ring road crew photo
and ariane like you've mentioned
multiple times new shepard is alive at
this point that booster is just waiting
for its crew and it's ready to go
on the right of this shot you do see
sarah knights our crew member seven
she's gonna accompany the crew up to the
tower and make sure they're situated in
the capsule in just a little bit here
that is a good looking crew
in fact while we got a moment here
they're going to get back into the
riviens why don't we get to know
sarah knight and our capcom kevin
sprogue just a little bit better we've
got a wonderful video to introduce them
to you
[Music]
the entire vision of blue origin is we
want to democratize space t-minus pen
you don't need to be a nasa astronaut
you don't need to be a trained engineer
we want artists and poets and teachers
and scientists to be able to go to space
this shepherd has cleared the tower crew
member seven is a position unique to
blue two assigned to each launch
there are six people that can fly in our
crew capsule the seventh person is the
crew member seven this is for real
the other crew member seven is called
capsule communicator and they represent
all of mission control and launch
operations to the astronauts
it took me a long road to get here i
spent over 20 years as a fighter pilot
at the united states navy but since i've
been eight years old i wanted to be in
space coming here to blue origin is the
realization of a childhood dream of mine
my background is in physics and
astronomy i went into stem education i
was a teacher for many years
and when the physician opened up a blue
i knew that was me
the fact that i'm crew member seven and
the visible point of our entire team
it's such an honor the asset decent
position is crew member seven is our
teacher part trainer and part guide
they're embedded with the astronauts
they're truly a member of the crew
they're going to live with you at the
astronaut village and conduct all of
your astronaut training
space flight is complicated but our
astronauts that fly with us will not
need to have a complicated view of
what's happening the rocket is
autonomous and all of the safety systems
are hardwired into the core
on launch day crewmember 7 is actually
going to walk you up the tower put you
in your seat in the capsule close the
hatch
[Music]
the capcom will then take over as the
astronauts take their journey to space
and then as soon as they land
crew member 7 will be there to help open
the hatch and whisk them away to the
celebration
our astronauts are one part of a very
historic journey
we're trying to build the infrastructure
to get millions of people living and
working in space so the people who come
here will truly be helping us take that
first step
[Music]
they are in wonderful hands with kevin
and sarah you can say that again i mean
you know with kevin's military
background
that that discipline the rigor you've
got sarah with her academic background
she's uh an incredible teacher the two
of them work together so where they're
very different styles but they work
together so well i can't imagine a
better team to be guiding our astronauts
through this entire experience
thank you again everybody for joining us
live if you've just joined us we're at t
minus 33 minutes to go until launch our
second human flight our astronauts are
ascending the tower here as you can see
we've got uh the great william shatner
we have our blue origins very own audrey
powers as well as our two customers
uh glenn devries and chris boshhausen
who are ascending the tower as well and
they are being uh they are being greeted
uh and hosted up the tower by uh our
founder jeff bezos so an incredible uh
morning for all of them as well as for
us at blue uh cannot wait
it's the same energy that was that we
felt down here just a couple of months
ago when we had our first human flight
and let me tell you this doesn't get old
when you put people on board a rocket
this doesn't get old and i can tell you
you know i'm very close with audrey
powers of course as a close friend and
colleague i've known chris for over a
decade
it's not just putting people on board
but you know when you know them this
i've i'm i'm having i'm having a moment
myself honestly and when they take off
it's uh
glad you guys are going to be watching
the rocket because i might
lose it a little bit i do have to say
also know audrey very well and got a
chance to talk to glenn a little bit and
actually glenn and i are both carnegie
mellon alumni i had to toss that in i
know tartan's in space you know we have
to um and i know that everyone you know
glenn's from new york everyone in new
york is watching and his adopted
pittsburgh family i'm sure is watching
as well so it's it's very personal
seeing this crew fly today well and in
addition to
you know chris is the first full
australian to fly to space there have
been other australians but they've been
dual citizens chris is the first full
aussie to fly so hello to all of our
international viewers especially those
down under we're so excited to have you
joining us and of course
of course to all the trekkies out there
that are joining us thank you so much it
is a pleasure and an honor to be sending
uh captain kirk to space today this is
going to be a really really cool moment
uh and when i say you know it comes from
all of us there you see are a shot there
just a moment ago of mission control
they are you know
focused and it's a very disciplined team
team that has been uh trained over over
months and years uh in the case of many
of our team members there right and
they're led today by nick patrick flight
director nasa astronaut they're in very
good hands
and here we have the crew they're
entering the shelter just to await their
ingress across the bridge then the
gantry and of course into their seats in
the crew capsule each of our astronauts
is looking great and ready to fly today
in those blue origin flight suits
fantastic so you see sarah knights at
the bottom of your screen
or crewmember7 she in just a moment here
is gonna go she's gonna leave the
shelter she's gonna go out
across the bridge just check in with the
tower crew make sure that we're all
ready to go and then she's gonna come
back
to the shelter
and take the astronauts out out to the
rocket
and once the astronauts head out of the
shelter you will see them ring a fun
ceremonial bell so that will come up
later if you're wondering what they're
doing at that point it's a little
tradition that we started at blue make
some noise before you get in your crew
cabinet that's right that's right let uh
let everybody up in space know that
you're coming
they can't hear you up there just just
just as a reminder
but hey we are at t minus 29 minutes to
go here why don't we take a moment and
check out new shepard as she awaits her
astronauts
and here they go there's glenn devries
chris boshausen
william shatner
and audrey powers
and today's special crew member eight
jeff bezos and crew member seven sarah
knights
there we have our awesome tower crew
ready to welcome them
there you see audrey giving some hugs to
the tower crew she is of course our vice
president
of mission ops for new shepard so of
course she knows the whole team very
intimately a lot of the team today are
launching their their boss to space
first first jeff now
and there goes glenn
into the hatch he goes all of this is
very carefully coordinated you practice
this
many times during the rehearsal you know
you basically you go in
walk in you kind of walk uh clockwise
around the uh the escape motor which is
in the center of the capsule and take
your seat that of course uh then you
harness in you have practiced this many
many many times during the during the
training uh and then you'll have uh crew
member seven sarah knights in this case
who's gonna come around make sure you're
properly harnessed in and make sure
things are nice and tight yeah and
ariana i know you've mentioned me before
you board from the highest seat number
first and then uh the seat number one is
the last board which is of course audrey
powers today
and there goes william shatner
one last photo off before what a surreal
moment
captain james tiberius kirk
is boarding our blue origin spaceship
ariane i know you've discussed your
astronaut training extensively
now
obviously buckling the seatbelt is a
very important part and they've
practiced this at this point what
hundreds of times i don't know about
hundreds but certainly dozens and dozens
of times you can do this
as i've said before upside down inside
out upward backwards and forwards and by
the way it's important that you can do
so this is probably the easiest moment
a little bit more complex is of course
when you're getting back in your seat
after you've been up there at zero g to
get the harness to get into the harness
and then of course buckle it properly
but again under the guide of of sarah
knights they they know how to do this i
was actually asking them earlier uh you
know who's who's the fastest at it and
they said of course audrey powers was
because she's done this even more than
they have so she had kind of a leg up on
them
there's chris boshausen in the window on
the left
and there goes sarah knights our crew
member 7 into the capsule
to do last minute harness and safety
checks on the astronaut there is audrey
on the left
once crew member 7 is of course
comfortable that all of our astronauts
look at their smiling faces from those
big beautiful windows once sarah makes
sure all of our astronauts are ready to
fly today and they close that that hatch
of course we'll turn it over at that
point to crewmember seven's other half
kevin sprogue who'll be the voice from
above the capsule communicator
touch
flu control has first stepped clear
and there you heard some initial
communications between capcom and the
capsule
there goes sarah knights making sure
the harness is nice and tight we see
just the just in the corner there the
hands of glenn devries quick thumbs up
two big thumbs ups yes
i had the chance to chat with him uh
just a little bit the other night and it
was
it was wonderful i said you know
glenn what do you think you're going to
think about once you're harnessed in he
said
he said as much as i've been dreaming
about going to space since i was a
little kid
until you were up
on top of that rocket
harnessed in he's like there's only so
much pretty mental preview of it that
you can actually get he said
he almost just pulled a blank he said i
don't know but i cannot wait for that
moment
glenn that moment has arrived you and
your three co-crewmates are about to go
to space and back i hope you are taking
every mental note there is and i loved
one thing from that interview that chris
and glenn our customers both actually
said when they told their family and
friends that they're gonna go to space
on new shepard there was pretty much a
universal well finally it's about time
it's about time you've been talking
about this pretty much since birth so
we're really happy to hear that this day
is finally here for chris and glenn and
of course audrey and captain kirk
blunt even said he's like you know what
i haven't heard from some i haven't
heard from a couple of friends since
kindergarten and they've reached out to
me and they said yeah you were talking
about this when you were five can you
imagine i think one of glenn mentioned
one of his special guests is his middle
school classmate
um who had to be here to see this day
finally happen
how do you
read loud and clear
loud and clear we are at t minus 19
minutes and counting
and we'll keep you updated on the count
as we go for now sit back and relax
you're gonna see jeff in just a moment
and there they are you got it there the
uh the welcome from capcom kevin sprogue
all four astronauts in their seats clear
communications you heard astronaut
powers astronaut lemly that is uh the
call sign for for uh william shatner
captain kirk there a reference to his uh
to his children to his family uh then of
course uh astronaut uh crispy he he also
has a dj on the side dj crispy and then
of course our other customer astronaut
devries glenda breeze in the final seat
there all look all sorted and ready to
go to space again if you're joining us
live we're at t minus 18 minutes to go
until launch our second human flight of
new shepard
just another extraordinary day for uh
for obviously our customers for our
astronauts but for blue origin thank you
all for joining us from around the world
for this event
we've got a couple more minutes to go
why don't we toss it back to the rocket
and check out new shepard as she
continues to be ready for launch this
morning
and there is jeff bezos closing the
hatch
jeff of course now an experienced space
traveler himself
i'm sure he imparted some some wise wise
words for our astronauts of course he uh
and his uh his co-astronauts on his
first flight had a ball
up in space and uh
maybe he gave them a couple of tips on
how to toss the skittles just right
it's all in the wrist it's all in the
wrist
i'm still surprised he got out of the
rss first step
yes it's true we do indeed only have
four astronauts in there today i know he
had such a good time uh that was a
question but no so there you see him uh
crossing the the bridge
our tower crew doing some final checks
on the uh on the capsule
the the capsule hatch actually has a uh
a redundant system in it so it is closed
they're gonna do a pressure test make
sure uh the the seals are
are all working correctly um and
this this vehicle what's really nice
about obviously they've got um they've
got their sweet flight suits right
because you got to feel like an
astronaut when you go up into space
but at the same time though the it's a
it's a pressurized vehicle so it's a
shirt sleeve environment they don't
necessarily need that what they also
don't need is a helmet because
we wanted our customers to get this full
unencumbered experience uh and to be
able to appreciate the view the view and
the sounds or the lack thereof that is
of space once you're up in space and so
again everything about this capsule has
been designed for the human space flight
experience
all right we are at t minus 15 minutes
to go here we are in a brief hold our
four astronauts are in the capsule and
ready to go let's continue to watch new
shepard as she gets ready for her flight
to space this morning
thank you everybody for joining us live
from west texas here at our launch site
one we are 15 minutes away from launch
we are in a brief hold here but while
we're in a hold i understand that capcom
in our mission control has a special
message for our astronauts we're going
to await that message here in just a
moment
i've got a surprise for you today
we asked our
ns16 crew to
send messages to you before your flight
so i'm going to read those to you right
now
right now
new shepard astronaut oliver damon and
it says dear ns18 travelers
you have probably been playing this
moment over and over in fox and also
quite often in real life in the case of
mr shatner
but now the moment is there the moment
you're really going to space
and i can assure you that it will be
better than your best imagination
no day passes by that we don't look back
on this journey without having a smile
from ear to ear
have a safe flight and enjoy
and enjoy greetings from your youngest
predecessor
oliver damon
i hope this fight will be the most
fantastic experience of your life as it
was mine
take time to enjoy every aspect of this
journey
from liftoff to touchdown
jeff has done a magnificent job of
ensuring the smoothest most memorable
ride
and kevin and sarah are top-notch
instructors
becoming part of the blue origin family
is an honor like none other i have
received
together let's cross new boundaries and
set new records
i
i will be watching your lift off with
great enthusiasm and sending my best
wishes
godspeed audrey bill glenn and chris
very much love dwali
new shepard astronaut demo
whose real name is mark bezos
has this to say
you lucky pastors
it was only 10 weeks ago that i was
sitting where you are
watching the countdown clock
full of anticipation and excitement
eager to feel a rumble of liftoff and
the majesty of weightlessness
the depth of my desire to fly again is
hard to express so allow me to quote
from the classic of the great american
songbook mr spaceman
with lyrics by william shatner
[Music]
[Music]
won't you please take me along
for a ride
godspeed new shepherd i can't wait to
hear your stories
what an absolutely special moment from
today's second human flight crew hearing
from our first human flight crew those
words of encouragement from oliver wally
and mark bezos the crew before this
amazing community of blue origin
astronauts and i i loved that that part
in one of the notes where they said look
when you when you go on one of these
flights you become part of the blue
origin team and really the blue origin
family and that is really you know
how we think about every single
astronaut on that vehicle today you're
very special to us you are going to have
the flight the ride of a lifetime uh you
are you are living our own dreams
through you guys so soak it in now we
are at t minus 15 minutes to go until
launch we are in a hold here but as we
have a moment as we tick down to launch
why don't we get to know the man that
many of you are here to see william
shatner
i'm going up into space
i don't know how many people who can say
that
it's life-changing in its way
not because of the
aerial adventure but because the people
i'm meeting and talking about i'm glad
to be here jeff bezos concept to make
living
and building in space and to make
pollution a thing of the past i mean
what noble ambitions those are and
somebody has to start lands
we're just at the beginning but how
miraculous that beginning is
how
extraordinary it is to be part of that
beginning
there is this
mystique of being in space and that much
closer to the stars and
being weightless
i shall be entranced
by the view of space
i want to look at that orb
and appreciate its beauty and its
tenacity
is sustaining
this life
of ours
which allows us to look
with awe and wonder at the miracle of
space
there is an adventure
in my life that i would not have had had
i not done this
and it looks like there's a great
curiosity
about this fictional character captain
kirk going into space
so let's go along with it and enjoy the
ride
it turns out william shatner is
everything you'd hope for in war we are
just so honored to be able to have the
opportunity to send this man to space at
the age of 90 no less remarkable he will
become the oldest person to have ever
flown in space and i know jackie
somewhere out there leonard nimoy is
smiling all right we're just at t minus
15 minutes to go we are in a hold here
why don't we send it
back to the pad continue to watch new
shepard as she readies for her flight to
space today
this
so
so
so
thank you again everybody for joining us
live for new shepard's second human
flight we are t minus 15 minutes to go
we continue to be in a hold here but as
you can see there the uh tower crew has
descended the stairs of the tower they
have gotten back in their vehicles and
they are headed back to mission control
that indeed is a wonderful sign
that we look forward towards this launch
this morning the weather looks good as
you can see here we are continuing to
make sure that the rest of our teams are
aligned though and again if we need to
take a couple of minutes uh as we uh as
we prepare for this rocket launch that
is quite all right
we have talked about it extensively
jackie the beginning of this show safety
is number one we want to make sure that
everybody in that mission control as
well as on top of that rocket is ready
for flight today and with that
everybody we have cleared the hold we
are at t minus 15 minutes to go now 14
minutes and 50 seconds
let's like this is this is what rocket
launches are about it is really exciting
and i i
i'm just happy to be sharing this moment
with you jackie i am too and i'm also
very happy to see continually smiling
faces out of those capsule windows that
is great uh great sign for today's
flight yes they are all ready to go our
four astronauts
why don't we take a moment jackie and
talk through the flight profile for
today's launch that'd be great so as you
can see here in the flight profile the
new shepard will lift off from launch
site one here outside of van horn texas
once a new shepard has lifted off it'll
approach that carmen line the 100
kilometer internationally recognized
line of space and at that point our
capsule with our crew will separate from
that booster and the capsule will
continue on over that karman line into
space the capsule at this point full of
crew who are unbuckled floating around
and getting their three to four minutes
of microgravity while they're having a
great time hopefully doing backflips not
forgetting to look out that window the
booster is headed back down to earth so
those wedge fins at the top of the
booster will be the first to deploy on
its way back
and then as the booster continues down
we will put out those drag breaks the
booster is coming down hot at this point
very fast those drag brakes will
significantly slow it down
as we approach the landing pad that be 3
engine will re-light
it will hover which we often are asked
if that's cgi it is real
that hover and then the booster will
softly touch down in the west texas
desert the capsule meanwhile on its way
back to earth the first thing to happen
here is those drogue parachutes will
deploy slowing down that capsule
followed by the beautiful big main
parachutes and then just before that
soft touchdown we do fire some retro
thrusters they do kick up a bit of dirt
out in west texas but that does ensure a
very soft touchdown of about one to two
miles per hour for our clear our crew
out there it really is a soft landing
back down here in the west texas desert
and as a reminder you know this is the
standard flight profile we are now in
full customer operations but we have
tested this flight profile and vetted it
across several flights over the last
several years we had 15 consecutive
flights remember before we decided to
put people on board we wanted to make
sure that we understood the not just the
vehicle in nominal conditions but to
really push the envelope and stretch the
vehicle to make sure that it was a
robust vehicle for our customers and of
course you heard about how we think
about safety and development throughout
the culture but also in the operations
manufacturing etc from andrew lake who
joined us on the show a little bit
earlier
all right with that we are at t minus 11
minutes and 50 seconds to go until
launch our four astronauts are in the
capsule harnessed in we see audrey
powers on the left you can't quite see
it but going clockwise we have uh
william shatner then chris boshhausen
and glenn devries in the capsule all
ready to go for launch as we tick down
here
let's take a moment continuing to gaze
at our beautiful rocket as she prepares
for flight this morning
here we are at just about t minus 10
minutes until launch with our astronauts
and especially our customers glenn and
chris on board there's really no way to
fully understand how they're feeling in
this moment without being on there but
we do know someone who has experienced
this and can share a little bit about
that our first customer oliver damon 18
years old the youngest person ever to go
to space let's hear it from him
there was not a single moment in life
that i thought that would be the
youngest astronaut ever
and to have been given this chance by
blue is so amazing
to meet the other astronauts
and see everything is so cool
we'd like to run this one through at
full speed we're going up to that
tomorrow yes we are i think there was
not a single nerf in my body that was
like afraid i think it's because the
track record of blue
the launch and the power of the cheese
like you're going up to the sky
and of course weightlessness
[Music]
pretty cool
what i've just been through i've been
dreaming about all my life
let's hope that many many more people
can do this because this experience you
should share with more and more people
it's so amazing
[Music]
oliver's perspective for someone so
young is just amazing i'm so encouraged
by this next generation i actually did
like the part where he said he's been
waiting for this his whole life he's
substantially younger than me so i'm
still a little bit jealous of oliver
we're at t-minus nine minutes until our
second human launch awaiting the go
no-go poll
and uhf for the gopul for terminal count
and launch capsule
go
booster go
ground
go
safety
go
capcom
go
engineering
go
this is the flight director on channel
one and uhf voice
booster commence the terminal count
copy fighter
as you heard it we are go for launch go
for second human flight i am so excited
for this crew now earlier this week i
sat with him to discuss rockets and
space in the future let's get to know
our crew a little bit better
all right guys you're just a couple of
days at this point from going to space
anybody anybody excited
a little bit something just a little bit
you are i am i'm excited for you guys
i'm glad and chris in particular you
have bought these tickets to go to space
why yeah
the the ticket is for the view the
ticket is to really get that
understanding of what what it's like to
see earth from that perspective and
and
feel like we're part of this tiny little
planet and this little civilization that
that frankly has a lot of work to do to
make earth work better to make it more
sustainable and and i want to carry that
feeling um that we're going to get from
that view back down with me and uh and
hopefully turn that into making the
world a better place and frankly i think
being able to do that
is something that can not just be great
for those of us who have the privilege
of being able to do this now but will
fuel this industry that will allow us to
have as many people as possible on the
planet see that
and everybody benefit from the things
that are going to come out of space and
space technology yeah i mean this is you
know for me the you know for personally
a lifelong dream but i realized that you
know this is the space is opening up for
everyone you know this is the beginning
of a new era right the first 60 years of
space exploration with the domain of
governments you know you had to be a
space superpower to send highly trained
astronauts into space
and you know glenn and i are just
regular citizens flying up you know it's
it's amazing that this is happening i
think in about 60 years we'll look back
at this year and go this is the year the
doors finally open for the human race to
go to space fantastic and audrey
you know we we both have talked about
going to space for such a long time what
do you want to do with this experience
well aspire i can't wait to get back to
everybody at blue and have them pepper
me with questions you know the folks who
have designed this vehicle and tested
this vehicle and just haven't asked me
everything they want to know about what
it's like when you're up there and my my
nieces are coming to to watch this and
they're you know teenagers young young
kids now and they're just just
absolutely mesmerized by this kind of
stuff my friends kids are all you know
their girl scout troops are calling yeah
so i can't wait to talk to all them
fabulous and well bill we'll end with
you you have inspired so many for for so
many generations for for the kids and
the young people that are going to be
watching this launch and who might want
to be space explorers one day do you
have any any words for them well
seriously the truth of the matter is
this whole blue origin thing is based on
the idea of building industry above the
earth and taking that pollution
out of this planet out of the immediate
planet and putting it up there
that's got to be the future of the earth
and the and and the earth is
is dependent on that and the youth so
the two work hand in hand and so it's
very important that the young people of
today know that that up there is the
future and to work towards that
for the improvement of the earth
fabulous well thank you all for for
coming on this journey with us as blue
origin but thank you for for inspiring
others and also as we go forward coming
out of this continuing this inspiration
so
thanks guys good luck godspeed
wow well some great perspectives from a
crew that's clearly more than ready to
fly to space today
well we are just under t-minus five
minutes until liftoff so things are
getting real things are getting really
really and what i really loved about
that video is
this crew gets it right every single
person on that rocket gets it how
important
going to spaces of course for the for
the ability to have that incredible view
and the incredible experience of being
in zero g but also to inspire others and
and understanding what the road to space
is about and why we're trying to
ultimately have millions of people
living and working in space to make life
better back here on earth and a big
thing they all talked about that is
truly so special is you know everyone
wants to know how those three minutes
were in space but they're excited about
what comes after you know and i think
that's just something really really
special about this crew their focus on
like you said inspiring others after
this flight long after this flight is
over exactly all right so again t-minus
three minutes and 50 seconds to go until
launch
what's coming up shortly here so at t
minus two minutes we send the show over
to new shepard she's a fully autonomous
vehicle which means that from t-minus
two minutes through launch up to apogee
and back down to landing the rocket is
in control of itself of course we have a
an incredible team in our mission
control center that have their eyes
glued on their screens to make sure that
everything is going well and has been
within bounds but
we built the rocket to be autonomous for
safety again we kind of we think that
while we've got some pretty smart uh
people in that mission control the
rocket is in fact quicker and faster at
controlling itself so what we're going
to see here shortly the rocket is going
to go through what we call the bit
checks the built-in tests at the base of
the rocket you see three of the four
fins down there
those are the aft fins those are going
to uh move back and forth we want to
make sure that they've got full freedom
and of movement
also what you're going to see at the
base of the rocket you can kind of see
it's a little hard in this image you're
going to see the engine nozzle gimbal
the the engine moves back and forth it
also uh helps with the directional
capability of the rocket on ascent but
also especially on decent as it comes in
to land on the landing pad just two
miles north of where it's taken off from
and then of course you've seen
throughout the morning the rocket
venting we it's full of propellant at
this point but we want to make sure that
we keep the propellant the propellant
tanks within bounds of course of
pressure and temperature
this morning a little bit easier to do
that uh versus our last flight which was
in the middle of july it was warmer it's
actually a nice a nice balmy morning
morning here down in west texas but
again we've got our team who have their
eyes on their computer screens making
sure that everything is in within bounds
and there goes the gantry retracting
at t minus two minutes let's listen in
there go the aft fin checks at the base
of the rocket
our astronauts can feel that they are
sitting at the top of a 60-foot rocket
about 20 meters tall
t-minus one minute
and there you can just see
slightly there the gimbaling engine at
the base of the rocket
all right everybody chris boss housing
glenda breeze audrey powers and william
shatner are about to go where very few
humans have gone before
ladies and gentlemen it's time to launch
this rocket godspeed new shepard
minus ten
nine eight
seven
six
five
four
manage and start two
one
[Music]
has cleared the tower she is on her
space with the second human space flight
crew
what a launch we are on our way to max q
the first milestone here on its flight
to space
[Music]
you can follow along obviously with the
altimeter at the base of the screen as
well as the speedometer they are gaining
speed on their climb to space we have
confirmed
max q this is when the mat the the
aerodynamic stresses on the vehicle were
at their maximum
[Music]
[Music]
thank you again everybody for joining us
live for new shepard's second human
flight with audrey powers william
shatner our customers glenda reese and
chris bosshausen on board they are well
on their way to space so far a nominal
flight a clean burn on our blue engine 3
new shepard giving them a beautiful
flight to space this morning
the rocket is climbing towards an
altitude we're aiming just over the
carmen line the internationally
recognized line of space of 100
kilometers that is about 328 thousand
feet
and a gorgeous view down the rocket
and now we've had main engine cut off
the be3 engine has shut off and in just
a moment we're going to separate the
capsule from the booster and at that
point our astronauts will have the
opportunity
to get out of their harnesses and enjoy
the beauties of zero g
let's wait to listen
and there you can see a clean separation
between the capsule and the booster
and there you can see the capsule from
the top of the booster
they are continuing their ascent over
the karman line you'll know when they
hit apogee when the speed hits zero
and there they are over 328 thousand
feet over 100 kilometers welcome to
space
the newest astronauts on board our crew
capsule
and there they are they have hit
just about hit their apogee
at about 351 000 feet
and while we don't have apogee i can
just imagine jackie they are having the
time of their lives
thank you again everybody for joining us
live from west texas so far a nominal
flight for our second human crew
exciting jackie to have sent captain
kirk himself william shatner to space i
cannot wait to hear his commentary upon
return as well as our two customers
chris boss housing from australia to all
the fans turning it tuning in from down
under a big shout out to you guys as
well as glenn devries and our very own
audrey powers they are coming back home
the booster of course is going to beat
the capsule back home it is more
aerodynamically shaped of course at the
base of the the capsule it's kind of a
blunt end so it's less aerodynamic what
we're going to see coming up shortly is
at the top of the rocket we have the
ring fin the uh the there's uh some what
we call the pie fins that extend from
the ring fin uh as well as the drag
breaks the the uh the pythons the wedge
fins helps stabilize the vehicle uh like
kind of like the feathers of the back of
an arrow and then you will also see the
drag breaks and as you mentioned jackie
it cuts the velocity dramatically
there you can see the wedge fins are out
here we see the descent we are going to
expect the be3 engine to re-light just
about 3 600 feet or about 1200 meters
above ground level let's wait for that
now the drag brakes have deployed and
here we come new shepard
[Music]
and touchdown welcome back new shepard
the fourth flight to space and back for
that vehicle provided a beautiful flight
to space for our second human crew
wow that gets me every time we do this
live down here in texas the sonic boom
is so cool drag breaks are folding back
in as have the wedge fins
just looks like you could uh fuel her up
and go again what do you think jackie
and even when you know to expect the
sonic boom it still catches you off
guard every time talk about a rumble a
beautiful sight of our new shepard
rocket there in the west texas desert
but of course the show is not over the
capsule is descending we are waiting for
first the drogue break excuse me the
drogue shoots to deploy those are very
much like the guide parachutes they will
subsequently be
followed by the the main parachutes that
will fully that will first reef and then
fully inflate and there go the dro
parachutes
and here come the mains
what a flight
you can already start to hear the cheers
from outside the our our stage here in
west texas
i just threw a piece of parts call up
a lot look at me window audrey oh yeah
how about that guys how about that guys
that was unlike anything they described
all right
and here comes our crew back into the
desert
newest astronauts 596 97 98 and 99.
that's unlike anything you'll ever feel
and capsule touchdown
welcome back the newest astronauts
audrey powers william shatner our
customers glenda reeves and chris
poshausen
what a day for you welcome back
i cannot wait to talk to them jackie and
just get
what they experienced up there this
morning what a clean and beautiful
flight from the rocket for our
astronauts what an absolutely stunning
flight and i also loved hearing that
audio of them on their way back about
how this experience was for them and i
can't wait to hear their stories well
you you heard william shatner say this
is like nothing i've ever experienced
before so coming from a man who has
experienced space he's gone warp speed
and traveled the entire intergalactic
universe this was like nothing he's ever
seen before
what a day for our astronauts so now our
team is preparing landing safety
operations and recovery of our
astronauts from the crew capsule
will be on the ground at the landing
site to follow the action in just a bit
maybe even talk to the world's newest
astronauts
some absolutely breathtaking stuff and
all note that you're going to see our
the recovery team show up very shortly
because we actually send them out before
the capsule has landed because through
our modeling we get ver by now we're
very very good at analyzing where the
capsule is going to come down to where
we know
exactly where where the winds are and so
we're going to see the recovery team
come out there and of course they will
also be joined by some of their friends
and family to watch as they emerge from
the capsule let's check out these
beautiful shots of our four astronauts
there in the texas desert after having
gone up over the carmen line and back
oh
and here's some beautiful shots of our
four astronauts in the capsule awaiting
the recovery team i understand from
capcom that they have had communications
with those four astronauts and they have
all given the thumbs up that they are
doing a-okay after an exhilarating
exhilarating flight to space and back
awaiting that recovery team in that
champagne shower which i'm now
regretting that we don't have any
champagne for ourselves that feels very
unfair after the show
there's some waves from
from our astronauts there
there in the foreground you see the
capsule the background the ride to space
the new shepard booster again that
booster has flown to space and back four
times with this flight
and coming to get them is the recovery
crew
okay
and jack you can see there again
beautiful shots of the capsule the
parachutes actually have fallen pretty
close to the capsule itself meaning that
there isn't a lot of ground when out
there we talked about this earlier in
the show and of course we had to delay
a day because of the the gusty winds
that have been out there but no today
has been a beautiful day for a launch
and landing of a rocket and launch and
landing of four new astronauts
i know we were talking to chris a couple
days ago and he actually flew that usb
full of music from around the world to
space as you mentioned he's a dj so of
course we have our new astronauts we
have our club for the future postcards
that have just returned from space and
of course you know some of the personal
items like this awesome this awesome
awesome usb full of music i wish we
could be playing some of that right now
well you probably will soon actually you
know as we mentioned chris boshausen uh
uh has kind of a side gig as a as a dj
dj crispy and he actually released an
album on friday and uh i can't wait to
see what he does with that music
so musicians on board too of course
william shatner everybody knows him as
an actor he also sings i think that's
one of the most beautiful things about
what we're doing at georgian again
opening the door to more people to go to
space yes the scientists yes the
engineers but now the artists poets
let's
singers djs let's just see what they
create coming out of this experience we
have said it before going to space
changes you we've talked about the
overview effect and i i can't wait to
see
how
the the stories that come out of and and
the art that comes out of this all right
we now have sarah knight
going around the capsule getting the
thumbs up
from each of our astronauts
thank you
thank you again everybody for joining us
live from west texas where we have just
completed our second human flight of the
new shepard vehicle
our crew on board
the great william shatner now who has
become the oldest person to have ever
flown to space at the ripe age of 90
years old our very own audrey powers as
well as our two customers glenn devries
and chris poshausen our recovery crew is
out there and is about to open the hatch
there is our founder jeff bezos giving
the big thumbs up
[Music]
[Laughter]
very
[Music]
and here come their friends and family
[Music]
[Music]
are you guys ready
let me know when you're ready
yeah thank you thank you
again thank you everybody for joining us
live from west texas at our launch site
one
our second human space flight crew has
gone to space and back up over the
carmen line just over 351 thousand feet
we're awaiting jeff bezos who is now
opening the
at your hatch
[Music]
come on up here guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's audrey powers a big hug from her
sister
kirk himself the great william shatner
[Music]
our customer chris boshausen the first
full australian citizen to go to space
and back
and glenn devries
some big hugs from their loved ones
[Music]
that's what i thought you have to work
on it's so hard you have to
not only is it different than what you
thought
it happened
you know what my
guess is
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i want to hear this
here
[Music]
[Applause]
the champagne showers have become
smiles all around
william shatner taking in the
[Music]
the little things
and now you're staring into blackness
that's the thing
the covering of blue this
the sheep this blanket
and you're looking into blackness into
black ugliness and you look down there's
the blue down there
and the black up there and it's
it's just
there is mother
earth
comfort and there's
is there death i don't know is that
death is that the way death is weapon
it's gone jesus
[Music]
it was so moving to me
this experience has been something
unbelievable you see yeah you know
the weightless my stomach went up
ah this is so weird
but not as weird as the covering of
bloom this is what i never expected oh
it's one thing to say oh the sky and the
thing and then fragile it's all true
but what isn't true what is unknown
until you do it
is
there's this pillow there's this soft
blue look at the beauty of that color
and it's so thin
and you're through it in an instant it's
one of them
i'll think of it
is it a
i mean depends on how you measure
because it thins out but maybe 50 miles
but you're going 2 000 miles an hour so
you're through 50 miles
of whatever the mathematics fast yeah
you know it's like a beat and a beat and
suddenly you threw the blue
and you're into black and you're into
you know it's rods mysterious and
galaxies and things but what you see is
black
and what you see down there is light and
that's the difference
and not to have this
you have done something i mean whatever
those other guys are doing what if what
isn't they don't
i don't know about that what you have
given me
is the most profound experience
i do announced
i'm so
filled with emotion about what just
happened i i just
it's extraordinary extraordinary
i hope i never recover from this i hope
that i can
maintain what i feel now i i don't want
to lose it it's so
it's so much larger than the me of life
it hasn't got anything to do with the
little green planet
it has to do with the enormity
and the quickness and the suddenness of
life and death under all mine
it's so beautiful
beautiful yes beautiful in its way but
no i mean your words oh my words it's
just amazing i don't know i can't
even begin to express what
i
what i would love to do is to
communicate as much as possible
the jeopardy the the the
the moment you see how
the vulnerability
of everything it's so small
this
air which is keeping us alive
is thinner than your skin it's it's a
it's a
it's a sliver it's
it's immeasurably small when you think
in terms of the
of the universe
it's
it's not it's negligible
this air mars doesn't have it right
there
nothing i mean this
anyway and when you think away carbon
dioxide change to oxygen what is it
twenty percent something that level it
sustains our life
it's so thin
to to
to dirty it i mean that's another hole
shooting through it so fast so quickly
50 miles and you're just in black
you're in death
the moment this is life this is life and
that's that and it's in an instant you
go wow that's death
that's what i saw
that's amazing
i am
i am overwhelmed
i have no idea you know we were talking
earlier before going well you know it's
going to be different yeah it's going to
and whatever that phrase is you have
that you have a different view of things
it doesn't begin to
to
explain to to describe
what
well for me i mean everybody's gonna
but
and this is now the commercial
everybody
it would be
so important for everybody to have that
experience
through one means or another i mean
maybe you could put it on 3d and
wear the goggles
and have that experience i mean that's
that certainly is a technical
possibility
but but what you need also
we're lying there in
here and i'm thinking listen
one delay after another delay we're
lying there like how do i feel and i'm
thinking yeah the little jittery here
and
they move the page oh there's something
in the engine they found an anomaly in
the engine they found an anomaly
we're gonna hold a little longer or
you're gonna hold a little longer and i
feel this you know the stomach the the
the the biome inside
and i'm thinking okay
i'm thinking i'm a little
nervous here another delay i'm a little
more nervous and then the thing starts
by the way the simulation
is
they have to be worn it's only a
simulation
everything else is much more doesn't
capture doesn't capture the the and
besides which the jeopardy bang this
thing hits you
you know just getting up there bloody
gantry was about
oh my god what an experience
nothing nothing
it looked like you had a moment of
camaraderie with your oh we all hugs
each other you know you share it's like
being in battle together really
and there is this bonding of being
embattled
but you're also embattled
inside yourself oh my goodness
i have had an experience now
thank you again everybody for joining us
live our second new shepard
astronaut crew has made it home we just
heard some wonderful words from william
shatner captain kirk who finally had the
opportunity to go to space he became the
oldest person to have ever flown to
space at the age of 90 if you can
believe it he of course went up there
with our very own audrey powers
our two customers glenn devries and
chris bosshausen
jackie you heard what what william
shatner was saying
what
what a moment everybody needs to see
this the he was commenting on you know
the the fragility of it all just how
thin you think oh here we are it's all
covered in blue but then when you go in
a rock it go through it you see how
quickly it turns to black
i mean he was he was literally moved to
tears by it and and it is we've talked
about it before
rockets are
rockets with people on board is an
emotional experience
and right now we're about to see our
four newest astronauts be pinned with
those astronaut wings so let's check
that out
was your experience
i think
it'd take me a while to be able to have
to process that it was incredible it was
the most incredible thing i've ever
have the great honor
depending this on you
how many people have been where you have
it
if you
speak now as this thing is
fresh
well only fresh vlogging like chris yeah
totally immersed
in have the great honor of putting this
on you
welcome to a very small club
i'm very excited about your
ability to communicate this
it's so
important for so many people
oops this one bent
so am i do you have a spare one
i never wanted to tell them i'm spared
don't worry i'm sorry this is audrey's
see that we get a spare one for bill
real quick do you think you can
[Laughter]
she did
this is the hardest part of the mission
thank you
you're amazing
you're an amazing person
audrey
you're so deserving of this thank you
you've worked so hard on this program
and all your life
you've been dreaming of this
isn't that true
what a gift
sorry these things are tricky i can see
i have some more [ __ ] for jeff ashby now
[Laughter]
poor guy he had to do it but of a big
crowd
is this at the nomex is
thanks so much
okay guys we have four astronauts before
you
[Applause]
that was absolutely amazing as jeff said
we've got four astronauts before you
thank you everybody for joining us today
for blue origin's second human flight
of course a special thank you to chris
boshausen and glenn our customers we
look forward to in the next several
years flying more and more of you
customers from around the world and if
you watching at home are interested in
flying with us please go to blurring.com
and click on fly to space we cannot wait
to send you up
jackie thank you so much for spending
this time this morning on the desk with
you it was so much fun thank you ariana
it was an incredible day and i cannot
wait to hear the stories from these
astronauts especially audrey i'm so
excited to see her give her a big hug
and hear how her experience was
absolutely and we already heard from
william shatner and how he he's still
trying to find his words and certainly
glenn and chris who have vowed as well
to share the story with the rest of the
world cannot wait to hear that
everybody the road to space is being
built you're seeing it right here we
took a big step today and uh if you are
interested in joining our extraordinary
team please visit our website
yes please join us from two people who
have been at blue origin for quite a
long time please come join us and if
you'd like to commemorate the day
captain kirk flew to space we of course
have mission patches here you see it on
the screen apparel and other collectible
gear in the blue origin shop
everybody my name is ariane cornell for
jackie cortese and everybody here at
blue origin thank you for joining us and
until our next launch grid autumn
ferocitor
[Music]
so
you